[Música]
antes de él la fotografía de moda era
acartonada rígida estirada anclada en
las poses típicas de los años 50
arrasó con todo a principios de la
década de 1970 cuando trabajaba con las
ediciones británica y luego neoyorquina
de la revista vog una complicidad que
duraría 35 años hoy a los 82 años y a
pesar de un derrame cerebral sigue
ejerciendo nos reunimos con él en el
corazón del maguey parisino con su
familia para disfrutar de la exposición
que le dedica la fundación a cedín alaia
Arthur algor de asedina laya han
trabajado mucho juntos los maestros una
fructífera amistad
fue muy relajado
muy alegre y eso que no hablábamos en
mismo idioma
siempre estuve a su lado
necesitaba fotos y yo estaba dispuesto a
hacerlas
a cambio me dio ropa le gusta esta ropa
quédeselos y dime las fotos
la pasamos muy bien
y a los dos nos encantaba la buena
comida
era un gran cocinero
dejábamos de trabajar para comer
trabajamos mucho con Naomi
ya verán Naomi
está ahí en alguna parte
y podía conseguir lo que quisiera
tenía ese toque mágico
lo apreciaba mucho era un tipo muy
agradable
y también lo usaba para hacer las fotos
creo que representa un movimiento de
libertad en la fotografía de moda
trajo luz aire y movimiento a los
estudios
[Música]
y estaba muy en línea con lo que quería
hace quería que la ropa viviera en los
cuerpos de las mujeres
y sobre todo que los rostros de las
mujeres brillaran a través de la foto o
de la ropa una foto
caras
celebra el cuerpo a través del baile a
menudo es al natural uno siempre tiene
la sensación de que las fotos de arthus
algor son un poco El antes y el después
si hay que describir la obra de Arthur
algor es una obra de instantáneas por
eso hoy nos hace pensar en otras formas
de fotografía pero en aquella época creo
que hacía la diferencia entre sus
contemporáneos Arthur y su esposa Great
holby tuvieron tres hijos Sophie es
fotógrafa ansel es un famoso actor que
ha aparecido en las películas baby
Driver Bajo la misma estrella y West
Side Sorry entre otras y Warren es
cineasta que aprendió de su padre
creo que es la manera de entrar en
contacto con los demás Cuando uno les
hace una foto
para sacar lo mejor de ellos
le he visto trabajar muy a menudo cuando
estás delante de alguien que es un poco
rígido como yo por ejemplo
me habría hablado de algo completamente
distinto
y antes de que uno se dé cuenta Se está
riendo y hace unas fotos geniales
con ojos que brillan tienen la habilidad
de desarmar a la gente con su humanidad
ella es imán la famosa modelo se casó
con David
la he fotografiado muchas veces
es muy buena persona
[Música]
me encanta que pongan los vestidos junto
a las fotos
es genial
ella es Grace Jones
la cantante
había venido a dar un concierto cuando
la fotografía
[Música]
es la que más he fotografiado
Ahora tiene 56 años y sigue siendo
hermosa
[Música]
no hay día en que me hagan una foto oigo
la voz de tu padre
realmente me enseñó Cómo moverme como
estar delante de un objetivo me lo
enseño todo simplemente hablando Hazlo
así no Así no nunca muestra Las Palmas
realmente estaba aprendiendo
dominaba todos los ingredientes para
hacer fotos totalmente mágicas
[Música]
la otra gran cosa de su padre es que
como mujer joven nunca me senté insegura
nunca ni por un segundo
era como un tío en el buen sentido
nos divertíamos sin estrés sin gritos
nos tomábamos nuestro tiempo y siempre
terminamos el trabajo
atención movimiento luz natural y
sonrisas Esta es la ecuación de Arthur
alward para captar la libertad del
momento
[Música]